Sam my precious Sam okay Sam stay where
we can see you becoming parents gave
Claire and I a greater sense of purpose
every day bro we had new memories each
one sacred in its own way I know exactly
what you mean
[Music]
[Music]
grief counselor GM died I began to
notice these inconsistencies do you
remember where this was taken
yeah its Griffith Observatory I swear I
remember taking this photograph we but
we were in Seattle how would you feel if
you could no longer trust your own
memories remember the children's book
when you're growing up about the family
of bears the berenstain bears Berenstein
SDI they've been hard to reach lately I
just started noticing something isn't
like what kind of things we're living in
parallel universes can you picture the
monopoly man what's on his face
apparently it's never been the case the
Mandela effect either we're sliding
between parallel realities like a
simulation and it's glitching it to hear
yourself right now maybe it's in my head
clear but what it's not maybe none of
this is real
[Music]
what the hell is going on
I'm not crazy
I need to know the truth
what makes you think this is gonna bring
your daughter back anyway
I design games i code this is a
simulation who if this is cold and I can
do something
there's no small thing shutting the
walls down
there's something you need to understand
ideas are dangerous things
[Music]
you